non mais globalement que soit le premier
soir au deuxième soit on voit bien juste
que c'est un prétexte et moi ça me gêne
malgré tout que le mariage soit un tort
de gadgets juste passer à l'acte et
faire un peu du sensationnalisme voilà
et voilà on vient pas trop j'entends moi
je comprends que ça cartonne qui a tous
les ingrédients pour que ça cartonne en
revanche j'ai le sentiment qu'on fait
quand même tout pour qu'il touche le
premier soir ça ça me gêne un peu donc
il devrait avancer le pourquoi mais soir
jamais jamais parce qu'on m'a dit
[Musique]
[ __ ] on voudrait pas bon il est pas
bien il est pas bien laisser le choix
aux personnes de coûts déjà la maman de
yannick qui n'était pas quand tu écrives
quand son fils eut annoncé qu'elle
allait qu'ils allaient se marier
surtout avec une inconnue elle a
totalement changé d'avis et finalement
un arrêt ses ambiances et comme jamais
au mariage elle est née comme une folle
regarde maman je vais me marier avec qui
je participe à l'édition meilleure
voiture et c'est quoi le cancer
vous n'avez pas à ne pas s'y intéresser
1%
donc du coup ce que tu penses venir
reste que je me marie moment
non je fais lui pour toi toute la nuit
rés
l'équipe est la mère de yannick hamel il
faut savoir ce qu'on veut puisque l'un
dernière on a reçu sur le plateau une
jeune femme qui justement faisait pas
craquera qui est restée pendant des
jours comme les jours et demi pendant la
langue et on me disait mais non mais
quand même elle n'ouvrait comprendre le
jeu etc etc
donc on n'est jamais content en fait
d'accord et moi j'adorais un couple lui
les piliers de rugby 3e ligne est elle
allée ostéo kiné c'est un couple génial
ça pas gilbert délé ce qui m'ennuie
c'est l'hypocrisie c'est plus du
romantisme c'est de l'érotisme
il est dur où il se déshabille à l'écran
c'est pour lui dès maintenant que sa
mairie avait déballé la vie on a déjà vu
des mecs alors danser dans ce cas là
alors le truc là avec nos gros et denis
brogniart là où il fonde sur tf1 laïque
ans à dire dans ce cas là aussi c c c c
enfin lâché les habits pour coucher la
doudoune et doit sortir son mister
freeze nomade entre les filets sont
émerveillés de gens diront si les îles
sont au chaud entre eux s'est mis la
production et il faut la main mais jours
si on est amoureux on pousse le premier
surpris moi la vie qui a déjà coucher le
premier soir général à [ __ ] je perds
cela que je crève l'abcès
parce que j'en ai marre là tout le monde
en parle castaldi oui avec qui bazoum au
des questions non oui avec est ce
qu'avec une de vos fans vous avez couché
premier soit une entente avec mes fans
ont péri cochin question piraterie bon
paquet de 10 heures alors oui non pas
avec tous les femmes mais il y avait un
coton non mais ça m'est arrivé de faire
fondre les femmes mais je peux pas vous
le dire je m'en rappelle même pas
bouge à nathalie au deuxième foire pas
le premier modèle soit avec jean-pierre
non non le premier exemplaire avec un
bâton aequo avec un inconnu
c'est pas votre ba ouai ouhlala 10
minutes parce qu'elle a su pas bien ce
que je sache s'il vous plaît s'il vous
plaît laissez-moi mener cette enquête
seuls dont nathalie marquay-pernaut miss
france
2012 pour moi c'est cadeau vous venez de
nous dire et les jurés ont bien entendu
que vous aviez coucher le deuxième soir
avec une personne on connaît et
apparemment on la connaît
je ne vous demanderai pas de qui il
s'agit bien entendu vous le savez je ne
vous demanderai pas qui c'est est ce que
c'est une personne connue du tout le
monde
oui oui d'accord mais très bien elle
avait évoqué deux et je fais non merci
ont justifié on ne le dira pas nathalie
dire à ce qu'elles voudront le dira pas
maintenant si elle veut non
oui si c'est la loi
ah oui non elle accouche etc et yao
bombay deuxième soirée bah quoi j'étais
jeune ba écoute et non mais vous êtes
toujours jeune merci mais bon on était
jeunes c'est fou cette histoire
incroyable qui regrette a pas du tout
c'était bien beau d'avoir des canaux
cela et nous car pas les couilles alors
oui mais non c'est intéressant parce
qu'elle a osé le dire et c'est bien
bravo on salue ton courage bâtisse était
pas bien mais ça c'est un gars n'aiment
pas ça te regarde pas si c'est a demandé
quand c'est avec faye dunaway super coup
montiel tu sors et face de nous oui et
alors alors non y'a pas toi tu peux
rester l'affairé il avait une couverture
de presse à hilla fait jour ces bras si
l'on consommé rien du tout on sait qu'à
toi quand il avait l'air bien agitée
avec toutes ces histoires
vous sortez avec laurent voulzy
[Rires]